[Applause]
ah thank you for applauding that
horrendous misogyny and sexism if you
are in this Enclave what would you like
a wrap
about exact what okay this onclave you
forgo your suggestion too slow front of
the room this side what would you like a
wrap about Dunkirk Dunkirk okay big
Christopher Nolan fan there dun Kirk
okay middle middle this side what do you
want W up crochet crochet oh from a man
good for you for you know defying the
the gender stereotype back of the room
what would you like a wrap about Goku
from Goku from Dragon Ball Z and and
then storing the B storming the Basel
lovely stuff well you're very educated
crowd this
is I mean except for this bit
what
Dunkirk crochet storming the Basel Goku
from Dragon Ball Z and then this this
party bachelor party Are you a
Bachelor wait is there is this a mixed
gender bachelor party oh my you're doing
it so
wrong or alternately so right who knows
okay uh so gentle how how why is there a
why is there a mix What's Happening Here
ask him why not ask him why not God
you're the worst best man ever if that's
what you and I thought we'd bring the
girlfriends
yay well at least this is the start of
night you've got plenty of hours to go
and have some fun what's the name of the
bachelor fat
what his name is
fatty he he's Egyptian that doesn't
affect his weight
why okay fatty the Egyptian bachela
party no don't any of you take this out
of context me being like ah fatty the
Egyptian maybe that's why the crossing
out of Gaz is blocked right
um that was an excellent RI if if
incredibly
offensive let's do this red LD use those
long fingers and long appendage
to thing this is a freestyle that's a
rat made up on the spot about all the
[__] you said crochet Dunkirk storm in
the Bas steel Goku from Dragon Ball Z
and fatty the Egyptians mixed sex
bachelor party H and we'll have some
fun we're feeling super light Snoop cuz
we Drop It Like It's Hot over there the
shadowy area were like what not paying
attention never clocking on don't worry
opportunity was gone so we're rocking
some guy went berserk coming from the
sky hour 45 minutes me oh my the
shortest Nolan movie that you could ever
see Evacuate the Allies Over the Sea had
Mark ryance and Barry kowan they were in
the ocean boat they were flowing saving
Harry Styles multiple timelines I know
it's actually historical but my mind
focuses upon the movie shooting all the
horses lovely shot over there and of
course it it's a victory you pick for me
there I agree sadly never watch that
Dragon Ball Z so I can't say anything
about the anime he's got the little ball
that he likes to play assumedly it's a
dragon ball oh fills with Glee in the UK
we don't call it Z maybe call it Zed
instead there he's got the black hair
weird Villain at the top of the tower I
know it's big with the black guys they
be like yo Dragon Ball it provides
basically a template hey I'm feeling the
thrill we we we today we're going to
storm the bastile walking in heads on
the spikes break out everyone who do we
like my name is robier what's the
solution we have a brilliant Revolution
down with Aristocrats all Foy we don't
like Maran toet and we really hate Louie
storming prison breaking them free
fatties like you want to come play with
me oh my admission I'm Egyptian crazy
party yes I'm on a mission and your best
friend was like don't worry F I'm going
to make sure that it's insane yes the
most drunk that you've ever been of
course we're going to go to the bars
take off your shorts and dance but
what's this they start to twirl we can't
go to strip clubs why cuz there's girls
and they complain they get upset they're
like do you think this is appropriate
wait no we're not going to drink that
much we're going to behave oursel but
that's okay fatty soon yourself and your
gang you can do what separately break
off and this guy disrespectfully
inviting ladies let me say this loudly
you could do it in Egypt you could do it
in Saudi then the ladies they wouldn't
get the admission cuz they're not
allowed out without a man's permission
and that would suit you down to the
ground where would they be just sitting
round at home on their own that's what
they do all day while the time away what
by doing some
crochet
ah ah thank you for applauding that
horrendous misogyny and sexism you are
lovely my name is Chris Turner thank you
good night